in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Josh
and Ashley or with us hey guys how are
you
welcome welcome going where do you guys
live we live in winston-salem North
Carolina in the best state of America
that borders Tennessee well thanks
thanks for visiting appreciate you guys
coming over it's a wonderful town you're
from so you're here to do your debt-free
scream yes and how much have you paid
off we've paid off fifty four thousand
approximately awesome that's like just
over three and a half years
very good making what kind of money
during that time we started it we took
your class right after we got married
and we started about fifty household and
now it's just over seventy excellent
what do you guys do for a living I'm a
music teacher and and I work in the
technology Falco didn't brand and do web
site I think excellent very good cool
what kind of debt was the fifty four
thousand mostly student loans
unfortunately little credit card that
small credit card not not really
anything else it was the the big dog was
student loans so so most people get
married and they go wow look at all this
stuff later what made you guys get on
fire and decide okay we get married nose
down we're getting as cleaned up what
happened tell me the story yeah so well
we were going to church our church we
saw that your class was being offered
and we decided you know hey we we can
try this out and when you had said
something in the class when if God's
people were out of debt what could they
do for the kingdom and that really it
hit us you know pretty hard so and
that's that's one of the things that
I've remembered the whole time and since
then you know I'm listening to your show
every day while I code and stuff and and
you know getting more and more feedback
and and the the more look the closer we
got to the end of our paying off that's
the the faster we yeah one point I was
working last year when we could see the
light at the end of the tunnel I was
working for jobs whoa I just wasn't
ready to be done with it so both of you
were just completely on fire yeah we we
had we had six total
at one point she was I was coding at
work she was teaching lessons lessons
and working for churches singing and all
kinds of stuff and I was doing websites
on the side so together we had what was
the worst of the four jobs actually oh I
don't know they all were pretty good
okay I don't know no dogs on the bunch
no wasn't too bad you sound like a lot
of it had to do with your musical talent
right yeah okay
and obviously josh is he's coding
everything in sight yeah I was doing
picking you know several website things
on the side freelance and logos and
graphics and everything so now I get to
choose what I want to work on everything
and who you want to work with yeah
that's much better also I think another
thing that helped us is we were both
raised by our families to be really hard
workers and right and to work really
hard for what you want and what you have
my grandparents especially really raised
me to believe that I think that held by
her grandfather in particular he he has
this saying he asked me how I'm doing
when I'm working and I'm I say I'm
leaning into it and that's something
that he says not I'm not just standing
there working but leaning leaning into
doing it with a little bit all right
step 2 step forward that's make it
happen yeah that's very cool
so when how are you - or 2727 okay so
there's a 23 24 year old couple out
there just getting married listening
they got $50,000 and student loan debt
tell them how you did this what was the
key to getting out of that the work
obviously working and really being open
and communicating about it and not not
wanting to being okay with not being
like everyone else is getting married
right now and going out and buying new
cars and new furniture and your houses
and things like that yeah to be okay
with being where you are at that time
and just waiting for things and I always
say to have a plan you know to have a
goal and then take the steps intentional
steps like you say to towards that goal
so yeah cuz sometimes there's art there
are people and I've been that person in
the past years ago where you just you
work your butt off but without a goal
all you gets frustrated all right I mean
you don't get anywhere
yeah but when you got a target you're
aiming at now it's not ready fire aim
it's ready aim fire yes and that changes
everything
you guys are sharp young couple way to
go guys thank you very proud of you you
gotta feel great yeah we do lost a
hundred pounds but yeah yeah we've never
been able to come to Nashville you know
we were taking you know trips now that
we would never have been able to do you
know you live like no one else later you
can do like no one I was actually gonna
give ya I know your birthday was
recently so happy birthday for that but
I was gonna get some t-shirts for the
show but if they didn't fit in our
budget but on the t-shirt it was gonna
say I was gonna say Ramsey 2016 with a
big what am i coming to in 2016 I don't
want me in Washington I'm actually
effective we don't want to do that you
guys are incredible thank you so much
congratulations neat neat stuff all
right Josh and Ashley winston-salem
North Carolina fifty-four thousand
dollars paid off three and a half years
working their tails off making 50 to
70,000 a year count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
that's how it's done guys excellent and
you're 27 years old you're making 70 you
know how to work you know how to work a
plan your spouse if you are on the same
team and you don't have any debt you
know what you can do anything that's
what you can do man that's incredible